April Ryan is the longest serving black
female White House correspondent ever
she joined the White House Press Corps
back 25 years ago and has covered five
presidencies Ryan is the Washington
bureau chief for the Grio her new book
is called black women will save the
world an Anthem in it Ryan reflects on
her own experiences shares conversations
with black female leaders and lays out
the obstacles that many face and
overcome April Ryan good morning good
morning Michelle how are you first
that's the title in and of itself is a
pretty tall order how to how do black
woman do it how have they done it and
why are you sharing the Playbook I'm
sharing the playbook for one because now
is the moment we are seeing a change a
shift and no one is marking the history
and I believe from the unique perch that
I've been blessed to send in for 25
years I said I have to do it we're in a
moment where we have the first black
woman vice president the first black
woman on the U.S Supreme Court women are
everywhere domestic policy advisor Susan
Rice Shalonda young Office of Management
and budget I mean the list goes on and
that's just government and Kareem
Jean-Pierre in the White House briefing
when we cannot forget her but the list
goes on right in the church house the
schoolhouse government house in your
house so we have to do this I feel like
I'm in church with you right here
vaccine making in the medical profession
moderna and that was considered the
number one vaccine in Kobe people need
to understand we are now in spaces and
places that we've never been before and
no one is my talking the moment and I
have to because we are exceptional we've
been lifting the load from the time we
came to this nation to now and Beyond
and if you don't Mark the moment we will
forget the moment and the numbers will
fall your mother played a big role in
this book can you talk about that and
also talk about what your daughters
should hopefully take away from that
yeah my mother was a pioneering woman
herself she enabled so many young black
students at Morgan State University
until her death 42 and a half years I
don't care where in the world I go
people come oh I remember your mother
Miss Ryan it touches my heart my mother
has been gone for about 15 years now but
she told me I could be and do anything I
wanted to do and I believed her and now
I'm sitting as the longest serving
black female White House correspondent
in history right because of her the
strength the uplift the nurturing the
the recipe that they leave for us I'm
not just talking about cooking yeah I'm
talking about the recipe for life right
we hold up the home we we gird up our
children and we push them forward into a
society that doesn't always love us but
when we come back we know that we get
instruction love and Foundation from
that woman who understands the haunts
and the ghosts of the past and what lays
ahead for the future black women have
mastered the art of juggling yeah while
wearing the weight of the world on their
shoulders
um there's a lot of black women that
feel invisible yeah what is your advice
you mentioned occupying space some
people feel invisible in these spaces
and then some women need advice on how
to occupy space with your elbows out
what is what is your advice to them I'm
glad you brought that up I might have a
great story in this book from Valerie
Jarrett
um former advisor to former president
Barack Obama who says sometimes when she
shows up in these major rooms with world
leaders at the table she's like wait a
minute
do I belong here yes she belong right
this woman who has been a world leader
herself for sure and she comes from a
lineage of slavery of of the haunts and
the ghosts of slavery and many of us
walk into rooms and say okay I'm here
Shirley Chisholm said if you don't have
a seat at the table bring a folding
chair we are now convening those tables
have the folding chair on our back but
we're also making those solid chairs so
we can sit in and and and you did it in
the White House Press briefing room but
I stand on the shoulders of so many yeah
I stand on the shoulders of Alice
Dunagan and Ethel Payne the late great
Gwen Ifill Michelle so many women who
came before me and and poured into me so
I could stand in some of the toughest of
times and the best of times but I want
to get back to this invisible piece and
this is so poignant Valerie Jarrett gave
me a story a long time ago and she said
when we talk about invisibility think
about Michelle Obama that's right when
she was President of the United States
when they would go for their walks out
in uh beyond the White House
people would not recognize Michelle
Obama how can you not recognize about
that wow Michelle Obama invisibility
yeah right April Ryan we appreciate you
just like this cover you deserve your
flowers too as well yeah black women
will save the world it goes on sale
tomorrow